bonne rabier votre prénom je m'appelle
théo théo c'est bon ouais fait quoi dans
la vie je suis étudiant en sciences
économiques et sociales et à part ça je
vois aussi un petit peu au tennis
vous êtes coach de tennis oui je sais
qu'on m'a dit l'escroc alalala théo je
veux dire j'ai pas du tout aimé ce que
tu as failli écoute moi bien on va
s'affronter en deux balles chacun je
m'en fous sur deux derniers services
parce que tu me l'as tu m'as menti on va
voir raymond dans un instant on andre
agassi ça marche je t'explique si tu
perds tu m'offres un smartphone si je
perds avec art offre un smartphone c'est
fait et je suis étudiant je peux avouer
d'argent t'inquiète pas tu veux offrir à
nos cas avec le sieur avec le jeu du
serpent
t'inquiète pas allés voter bien non
feydeau dernière parce que je peux pas
rester comme ça l est avec son sourire
que tu peux mettre le truc on en est
loin de kilomètres on regarde tu vas
voir je vais voir merci parce que si
vous nous rejoignez il nous a menti il
usa il nous a caché qu'il était plutôt
celui voilà ce que c'est bon ça c'est
vrai c'est doit être à 30 800 km invasif
ont déplu démarre par les nazis le prof
de tennis non mais c'est un trial mija
monticule et quelques informations c'est
bon tout ce qu'il a fait mincir auto
tient 130 et bien et quand même il est
contre l autre et j'adore l'odeur ses
biographes et croit qu'il n'avait jamais
joué j'avais technique à toi je parte de
la barbade l'est syrie l'enlever
maintenant non non non je vais le faire
avec la veste vous inquiétez pas les
pertes ou slip à celui-là il est beau
tout neuf comment y avait au 1er juin
non mais c'est bien son attention pour
l'instant c'est moi qui te dois
smartphone sans doute je t'offre un
smartphone quand même c
non mais attends il était prof de tennis
à le bougre le bout et il ya toujours
les commentaires magnifique de maxime
ganis nous rejoignent et qui vient de
dire quel duel
heureusement qu'il est là